hello I'm John Taylor and this is the
corpus clock it's just struck three
we're in the workshop
just outside Cambridge where it's being
built I'd like to show you something
about it so where are the hands I wanted
to create a new and a different way of
showing time this is not a computer
generation but a true mechanical clock
to face the clock depicts time as a wave
coming out from the center of the
universe
every second runs round the dial a pulse
of light showing time racing away to me
time passes slowly or more quickly
depending on the circumstances time is
relative and as Einstein said an hour
sitting with a pretty girl passed is
like a minute but a minute sitting on a
hot stove seems like an hour
I wanted my clock to catch the observers
attention and to make them think its
heritage stretches back nearly 300 years
to John Harrison and his invention of
the grasshopper escapement
for the corpus clock
I have enhanced the image of the
grasshopper into a Crona phage munches a
minute every 60 seconds
this escape wheel is 50 times larger
than Harrison's original but it works in
the same way it is controlled
mechanically by the pallets which are
the lengths of the krona fish the time
is displayed by a series of vernier
slits and lenses hours minutes and
seconds the time is 11 o'clock
precisely
the vernier slits allow the passage of
light from a bank of LEDs that are
always illuminated and incidentally the
whole bank only uses 60 watts on the
inside of the escape wheel is the disc
of slits for the seconds the escape
wheel is driven by the clock spring
through these gears this carries forward
the drive for the minutes disc and then
the hours disc